[Musique]
je vous emmène aujourd'hui à Boston on
est dans le Massachusetts aux États-Unis
en France ou je ne sais où encore pour
vous parler aujourd'hui le produit alors
regardez j'en profite tant que je suis
là alors je suis là pour autre chose que
ça mais puisque on est là on va regarder
on va se parler de ça on va se parler
des écouteurs de Marshall alors vous
savez que j'aime beaucoup Marshall
design iconique sonde les gens j'ai
testé beaucoup de produits de Marchal
des enceintes des écouteurs bref
aujourd'hui on se parle d'écouteurs à
129 euros on se parle d'écouteurs qu'on
peut emmener partout facilement avec soi
un truc intéressant vous allez voir mais
on fait ça dans une ville qui est
complètement inspirante une ville
d'histoire Boston la Boston tee Party et
compagnie bref c'est une ville que je ne
connais pas que je découvre je suis à
peine pour 24 heures donc j'en profite
pour venir regarder découvrir vous on
s'inspire c'est un peu rock aussi Stone
il faut croire vous êtes prêts vous êtes
prêts vous êtes prêts allez on y va
[Musique]
je vous parle aujourd'hui des mineurs 3
des mineurs 3 de Marshall alors regardez
c'est juste ici vous les prenez le truc
qui est marrant avec ces mineurs 3 c'est
qui si vous n'avez pas d'embour silicone
donc vous les prenez et ça va venir
s'adapter aux oreilles de tout le monde
il va venir se poser à l'entrée de votre
oreille donc comme ici on a pas de
silicone on va pas venir non plus
obstruer bloquer le canal auditif ici il
y a pas de réduction de bruit passive il
y a d'ailleurs pas non plus de réduction
de bruit active ça vous permettra
d'entendre ce qui se passe autour de
vous d'être alerté si par exemple vous
vous baladez en ville et bien que il y a
une voiture qui passe on vous klaxonne
on vous fait coucou vous allez
l'entendre ça c'est bien c'est rassurant
je sais pas ça peut vous intéresser si
c'est d'ailleurs ce typologie de produit
que vous cherchez mineur 3 une fois de
plus je vous mets le lien en bas dans la
description
[Musique]
ces grandes églises et derrière te
retrouver avec des buildings il y a un
vrai contraste c'est pas uniquement ici
un ça on peut le voir dans d'autres
villes mais une fois de plus voilà il
vous faut profiter de ça Boston et à
garder il fait beau c'est l'automne ici
alors je connais pas une fois de plus
cette ville on est vraiment sur des
trucs très très très très très jolis
c'est hyper mignon donc on fait un peu
de tourisme on parle de dur en même
temps on combine tout et puis voilà pour
l'instant je sois très peaceful très
cool comme atmosphère et je trouve ça
super super agréable
[Musique]
à l'intérieur de la boîte je vous montre
ce que vous avez pour l'ouvrir il faut
venir hop là on pousse par ici on
récupère en bas alors vous avez
normalement ici vos écouteurs mais moi
je les ai enlevés dès que vous avez une
petite languette vous pouvez venir tirer
dessus et vous accédez à de la
documentation vous allez retrouver ici
alors c'est un petit guide de démarrage
tige de démarrage rapide dans toutes les
langues qui vous explique les fonctions
de base ok ici là vous allez retrouver
votre câble pour venir le recharger
directement en
USB a et vous avez de côté de l'usb-c
bon ok c'est simple et c'est tout il y a
rien d'autre ici c'est basique c'est
simple c'est efficace ça fonctionne
regardez là typiquement je suis en train
de me balader j'entends la voiture là il
y a eu un coup de klaxonne tout à
l'heure j'entends tout je suis alerté
donc ça c'est le côté très pratique
d'ailleurs je parle je m'entends
j'entends ma voix pas que dans ma tête
mais j'entends réellement puisqu'ici je
n'ai pas du tout de réduction de bruit
passive et qui deviennent juste se poser
et se reposer voilà comment ça
fonctionne maintenant on va aller par là
bordel l'eau c'est quand même vachement
mieux où welcome to Saint-Charles River
esplanade c'est là et surtout par là-bas
[Musique]
salut toi alors regardez là je suis
juste en train de me balader alors je
sais pas si c'est des oies ça ressemble
sans être sûr il y en a là-bas il y en a
tout au fond et là il y avait un
écureuil qui est parti je ne sais où
alors c'est très sauvage mais c'est
super beau c'est très peaceful la ville
pour l'instant de ce que j'ai vu ça
hyper calme cool détente alors il y a
des bagnoles là donc on est au bord de
la route mais aussi juste au bord de
l'eau et ça c'est vachement bien
vachement bien très reposant je sens que
ça va me plaire ici
[Musique]
côté design c'est simple on a toujours
cette étui noir avec le logo Marshall ça
avait le logo de légende on a toujours
ça de côté un peu granuleux qu'on
retrouve sur leurs amplis les écouteurs
avec de chaque côté regardez le petit
logo Marshall qui est posé dessus vous
avez dessous le petit bouton qui sert à
venir l'appairer vous appuyez tu peux
passer en mode appairage vous le
recharger ici en usb-c vous pouvez
carrément le recharger sans fil derrière
aussi c'est plutôt pas mal si vous êtes
amoureux de recharge sans fil et vous
avez une petite LED qui est je sais plus
où que je ne vois plus et qui vous
indiquera votre niveau de batterie
restant donc vers c'est bien rouge rouge
il faut commencer à le recharger mais
voilà sympa ça promet la lumière et
c'est très joli
alors qu'est-ce que ça raconte au niveau
de l'autonomie ça c'est le truc qui est
intéressant et que Marshall mais
vraiment en avant et en très gros il
écrit très très gros sur la boîte vous
montez jusqu'à 25 heures d'autonomie 25
heures voilà comme ça c'est plutôt bien
vous êtes tranquille vous avez 5 heures
par écouteur et vous pouvez faire
jusqu'à 4 recharges grâce à les tuiles
donc ça c'est extrêmement pratique et en
plus de ça vous le rechargez un quart
d'heure et vous montez jusqu'à une heure
et demie d'écoute si vous voulez le
recharger ça prend deux heures au niveau
de votre étui au niveau du boîtier et
une heure et demie par écouteur voilà
comme ça vous prévoyez vous êtes peinard
alors ça je trouve que c'est plutôt bien
et surtout ce qui est très rassurant
c'est les 25 heures les 25 heures elles
sont très cool parce que justement si
vous voulez l'emmener partout vous
balader sans vous prendre la tête du
point de vue de l'autonomie du point de
vue de la batterie là vous avez de quoi
faire 25 heures c'est long 25 heures
quand même regardez là-bas ils sont sur
un tournage alors il y a pas le même
matos ici c'est bien équipé mais ouais
plutôt bien dans le parc là regardez
sont cool ils ont le décor ils sont bien
ils en profitent et ils ont bien raison
[Musique]
bon écoutez technique est-ce que ça
raconte on a du Bluetooth 5.2 côté codec
on a de la PTX on a du SBC transducteur
de 12 mm et surtout le truc qu'il faut
savoir ici c'est que je trouve que la
qualité audio est pas mal ça se tient
attention on est à 129 €, on est sur les
écouteurs aussi ça peut pas être sur le
plus haut de gamme donc on va pas
s'attendre d'avoir un truc de fou si on
veut augmenter améliorer les basses et
avoir plus de basse que je vous
conseille de faire parce que vous avez
posé vous venez un peu appuyer dessus
pour les faire rentrer légèrement un peu
plus et c'est là où ça va venir
optimiser vous aurez un peu plus de base
donc ce truc là il est plutôt important
il faut bien le savoir la qualité est
pas mal on va pas s'attendre à ce qu'on
est une qualité aussi bonne que soit les
écouteurs très haut de gamme mais ça
reste convenable c'est correct si vous
voulez avoir des petits écouteurs
faciles pour venir mettre dans vos
oreilles pour vous balader en ville pour
rester attentif à ce qui se passe autour
de vous et bien vous avez un truc qui
est très bien on se retrouve toujours
une fois de plus avec l'esprit de
Marshall le son légende les guitares qui
attaquent un truc que je trouve cool
donc j'aime bien alors une fois de plus
qui me plaît bien ici et bien c'est la
marque parce que je vous le dis et je
vous le redis à chaque fois moi je suis
[Musique]
après ici sur vos écouteurs vous avez
des commandes tactiles comment tactile
qui se trouve forcément sur le côté sans
doute rat vous appuyez une fois lecture
vous appuyez encore une fois pose deux
fois morceau suivant trois fois morceau
précédent d'un côté comme de l'autre
facile autre choix de Marshall ici le
fait de ne pas avoir mis d'application
alors Marshall a une application je
voudrais déjà parlé je veux déjà montré
sur différents produits mais si c'est
pas le cas ici vous pouvez pas le mettre
dans l'application alors l'application
que sur la télécharger mais vos mineurs
3 ne seront pas reconnus donc vous allez
pouvoir venir les piloter directement
via la commande tactile ça veut dire pas
d'application ça veut dire pas
d'équaliseur ça veut juste dire une
fonction de base une fois de plus parce
qu'ils ont vraiment voulu rester sur
l'essentiel un tarif de 129 €
[Musique]
Eliott voilà donc il manque un T pour
l'appeler comme office mais voilà je
trouve ça mignon donc je vais partager
avec vous un truc que je trouve mignon
et qui me fait marrer à Boston là je
restaure je pense que ça resto légal si
food comme si il y avait je sais pas moi
de nourriture de la mer qui était pas
légale est-ce qu'il y a un resto illégal
si food allez savoir je trouve cette
ville juste super cool hyper détente là
il y a un bâtiment ça fait penser un peu
iron à New York regarder là c'est ce
bâtiment là qui part un peu de tous les
côtés d'un côté de l'autre un peu comme
le Fat ailleurs une fois de plus je vous
le dis que j'ai vu à New York j'adore
c'est hyper cool franchement petit petit
passage ici mais je regrette pas j'étais
jamais venu je sais pas si j'aurai
encore l'opportunité de revenir un jour
ici à Boston mais une fois de plus il
vous passez pas loin si vous allez à New
York vous êtes à quelque chose comme
4h30 de bagnole j'ai regardé ça vaut le
coup de venir d'autant plus qu'ici je
sais pas si vous le savez mais vous avez
une espèce de mégalopole qui part de
Boston qui fait Boston New York qui sont
jusqu'à Washington ça vous permet de
faire la cote est une partie de la côte
est sans forcément lescendre jusqu'en
Floride mais déjà c'est cool et la
petite rue regardez que je vois ça me
fait aussi rigoler un petit Little Italy
est-ce que c'est l'italien j'en sais
rien voilà fresh seafood cuisine
italienne on découvre la ville je
m'inspire et regardez c'est une fois de
plus je trouve ça juste magnifique
l'architecture et ce qui est drôle
encore plus ici c'est que vous savez si
vous êtes à New York c'est tout des
Russes et c'est vrai il y a des Russie
aussi mais c'est très rectiligne c'est
très rectangulaire ici c'est un peu
différent ça part un peu tous les côtés
j'ai l'impression que la ville a été
construite un peu différemment mais pour
autant elle reste à taille humaine c'est
pas hyper grand là je fais une balade
peut être quoi deux heures que je me
balade à 1h30 que je me balade dans la
ville mais je trouve pas ça hyper hyper
grand donc je trouve ça très cool là je
suis vers le Boston Plaza Park qui a
juste derrière moi ici et voilà donc
j'en profite en même temps c'est cool
donc on regarde tout ça qu'est-ce qu'on
se parle de ces mineurs 3 je reviens
dessus autre chose que je vous ai pas
encore dit ils ont une certification
certification
IPX4 à l'eau et elle a poussière enfin
l'eau c'est pas l'eau de pluie on va pas
lâcher sous la flotte mais si vous
transpirez est-ce que vous voulez faire
un peu de sport avec vous pourrez le
faire il y a pas de souci ça
fonctionnera voilà je crois que j'ai
globalement fait le tour c'est d'écouter
alors je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
comment vous les
de Marshall parce que vous aimez la
marque est-ce qu'ils peuvent vous plaire
il y a plein de produits chez Marshall
je vous mets bien évidemment le lien en
bas dans la description les jeter un
coup d'oeil il y a une gamme qui est
très complet je vous présente beaucoup
de leurs produits je l'aime beaucoup
chacun pourra y trouver son bonheur ici
c'est un produit qui est un peu
différent des autres mais que je trouve
très cool donc dites-moi vous ce que
vous en pensez en bas dans les
commentaires est-ce que ça pourrait vous
tenter est-ce que c'est minor 3 vous
hype vous butt ou pas dites-le-moi en
bas dans les commentaires et puis une
fois de plus merci à Marshall d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo et puis moi je
vais continuer à me balader à m'inspire
non mais regardez ça regardez ça cette
ville est dingue là on a un côté un peu
château fort avec le drapeau qui flotte
l'avion coucou là-haut ici à côté un peu
château espèce de tour puis vous avez ce
bâtiment rond à côté vous avez un autre
bâtiment ici je trouve ça marrant ça sa
vie c'est chouette c'est beau voilà vous
savez tout je vous ai tout dit pendant
qu'il y a le bus de l'école qui passe
juste à côté de moi dites-moi ce que
vous en pensez vous de ces écouteurs de
Marshall vous me marquer bien évidemment
on va dans les commentaires on se trouve
très vite pour continuer à parler tech
là je vous dis demain je vais aller voir
autre chose ici à Boston d'ailleurs je
suis venu pour ça j'en ai profité
d'avoir un très peu de temps aujourd'hui
pour faire cette petite découverte petit
tour de la ville et puis je vous ramène
très bientôt on part la semaine
prochaine à Hawaii il y a plein de
nouveautés plein de choses à voir plein
d'aventure donc ça c'est cool voilà je
vous embrasse à bientôt et prenez soin
de vous Ciao
[Musique]